all of us beat ourselves up too much the
place where everyone needs to be the
most selfish is in the way they love
themselves the way things are quiet for
me and not overwhelming is I'm my
biggest fan but not in a narcissistic
egotistical way in a I'm compassionate
to me you have to be nicer to yourself
we're human beings every person in here
is going to do something stupid today I
think I'm really good at business I'm
gonna make 150 big mistakes this year
having the capacity to be kind to
yourself and predicate it on your effort
is everything you know and that doesn't
mean don't hold yourself to a standard
that means just have more compassion to
yourself you're allowed to have a bad
hour you're allowed to have a bad day
you're allowed to have a bad week month
and you're allowed to have a bad year we
just need to be nicer to ourselves